the House of Representatives will have
an historic vote on impeachment this
morning while investigators look for
high-level witnesses to testify
meanwhile the watching post is reporting
that a White House lawyer put the
summary a president of trumps phone call
with Ukraine's president under high
security only after a concern national
security aide rushed into his office
Nancy Cordes is outside the House
chamber with more on this story so Nancy
what does this upcoming vote do and do
you think it's going to pass good
morning to you good morning to you well
this is the first vote on the
impeachment inquiry it establishes some
procedures going forward it has
near-universal Democratic support and so
it is expected to pass it comes as we
are learning some new details about the
handling of that controversial call at
the heart of this case lieutenant
colonel alex vind 'men the top ukraine
advisor at the White House testified
that he was so disturbed by the pressure
President Crump put on the Ukrainian
president in July that he rushed to
White House lawyer John Eisenberg's
office after the July 25th call
according to the Washington Post bin
Minh told Eisenberg that what the
president did was wrong
Eisenberg then proposed moving the call
summary to a highly classified server
and restricting access to it Eisenberg
is one of three major figures who
congressional investigators want to hear
from next week
another is the president's former
national security adviser John Bolton
according to one former White House
official Bolton used the term drug deal
to describe the pressure put on Ukraine
to investigate the president's campaign
rival Joe Biden if indeed what we have
learned is true that he thought this was
a drug deal he thought that mr. Giuliani
was a hand grenade then tell the
American people the president's top
Russia advisor Tim Morrison will sit for
a highly anticipated deposition today in
a surprise move last night the White
House announced Morrison was stepping
down to pursue other opportunities and
that he had been considering leaving for
some time cutting ties with the
administration makes it less likely that
the
president could compel him not to show
the top US diplomat in Ukraine Bill
Taylor testified last week that Morrison
had warned him the president doesn't
want to provide any military assistance
at all to Ukraine Taylor said he found
that extremely troubling the president
will be completely excluded from the
Intelligence Committee procedures
lawmakers debated into the night over
the rules that will govern the public
phase of this inquiry what you have set
forth here is not an open and fair
process we can shape our impeachment
investigation however we like everyone
here has been wondering will john bolton
actually come in and sit for a
deposition well his lawyer told CBS News
last night
quote Bolton is not willing to appear
voluntarily but I stand ready at all
times to accept service of a subpoena on
his behalf and Democrats will be all too
happy to issue that subpoena Gail if it
means that Bolton who sometimes clashed
with the president will come in and tell
them what he witnessed many people want
to know what he has to say thank you
very much Nancy
we'll bring you the results of this
morning's vote on the house impeachment
resolution and a CBS News special report
with Norah O'Donnell from Washington
this morning